okay I have something very different and
unique for you today Fox News reporter
Chris Wallace has called out Fox News's
totally biased and ridiculous reporting
on the Moller report and he did it while
broadcasting on Fox News Fox News hosts
calls out Fox News on Fox News that's
the headline and I want to kind of set
the stage for you here before we get to
the clip Fox News is a total right-wing
propaganda network that is almost
indistinguishable from the talking
points of the Trump administration at
this point in time that's the general
layout but there are two sometimes a
third person on Fox News who sometimes
are willing to tell pretty
uncontroversial truths which in the echo
chamber that Fox News has created can
actually seem notable or controversial
in some way and it's mostly Shepard
Smith sometimes it's Chris Wallace and
every once in a while there's this
FoxNews judge named Andrew Napolitano
who will say something accurate recently
he's had some pretty good takes on the
Moller report and on obstruction and as
I've said before normally when Shep
Smith and Chris Wallace quote tell the
truth it's really basic stuff like they
point out that a blatant lie by Donald
Trump is a lie okay it's relatively
uncontroversial but on Fox News that
gets our attention sometimes when a
trump official is dishonest Shep Smith
will just tell us that's not true you're
not being told the truth there um and
I've told you that it's a net plus to
have people like Shep Smith and Chris
Wallace on Fox News but that they're not
going to do any serious questioning of
the bigger contextual issues that make
Fox News a problem Shep and Chris are
what would be called safe dissenters or
calculated dissent so that Fox News can
actually say we're totally objective and
we allow diversity of opinion and all of
that sort of stuff but Chris Wallace
actually did something interesting
yesterday he actually said the opinion
programming on Fox News is pushing a
dishonest political agenda when it comes
to the Moller report and more
specifically when it comes to this
letter that we learned about
that was sent by robert muller to
William bard to say you're not really
representing my report accurately here
and here's the clip Chris Wallace again
is really focusing on the scathing
letter that Robert Miller wrote we
covered the letter yesterday Moeller
makes it clear that what the Justice
Department is doing in terms of its
representation of molars work is not
accurate and Chris Wallace calls out the
opinion side of Fox News you know I know
there are some people who don't think
that this March 27th letter is a big
deal and you know some opinion people
some opinion people who appear on this
network who may be pushing a a political
agenda but you know we have to deal in
facts and and the fact is that this
letter from the special counsel and it
was one of at least three contacts with
the Attorney General
between March 25th and March 27th was a
clear indication that the Attorney
General was upset very upset with the
letter that Benton sent out by the
Attorney General and wanted it changed
or wanted at least added to and the
Attorney General refused to do so he
felt the Attorney General's letter was
inaccurate
so just a chris wallace actually missed
speaks there and he says the Attorney
General was upset with the Attorney
General he meant the special prosecutor
Robert Muller was upset with the
Attorney General but good for Chris
Wallace but but but there is a but in
here which is that Chris Wallace
criticized just the opinion side of Fox
News which is a common thing that Fox
News defenders do they say okay listen
the opinion side has a right-wing slant
and that's okay because we're
counteracting the left-wing slant
everywhere else that this is their claim
not mine but the news side of Fox News
of which Chris Wallace is a part
actually does a really good job and
unfortunately the news side has been a
disgrace as well and Lisp lease power
Lisp our lease power from Media Matters
posted to her Twitter page an example of
the ridiculous coverage from the news
side of Fox News on this issue as well
here is a news show on Fox News
interviewing one of the most partisan
toxic actors in the history of President
investigations they interviewed Kenneth
Starr who you might remember
investigated Bill Clinton in the 90s
saying nothing to see here
in the Moller report nothing to see here
in the Moller letter which is of course
a blatant lie and Fox News host Bill
Hemmer allows it unchallenged including
that the letter from Bullard from Muller
to bar is just no big deal so this is
the news side being just as much of a
disaster take a look how do you size
this off and what appears to be at least
for the moment a story of he said and he
said sir yeah it doesn't I know a lot
it's being made out of it but it looks
to me as if at the end of the day
there's very little like this is a 440
plus page report as you pause through
the port it is so detailed and so
there's nuance there right so it's not
surprising that the author of the report
would say guy you didn't get it exactly
right but the key is did you get
something wrong
where were you misleading were you an
accurate as something as you said false
and and there bill bar against a 100%
grade so he gets an a-plus okay just an
absolutely fantastic handling by William
Barr
so listen Chris Wallace is write the
opinion side of Fox News is a total joke
on this issue but the Fox News News side
is just as much of a joke and maybe
dangerously more so because media
literacy is such an abomination in this
country that Fox News viewers are
watching News and thinking they're
getting or rather they're watching what
is effectively opinion but it's packaged
as news and they think they're getting
just the facts and not opinion when in
reality they're getting the same
echo-chamber a partisan nonsense that
Fox News does on the opinion side so
again good for Chris Wallace a Fox News
host calling out Fox News on Fox News
you don't see that every day you don't
see that every month you don't see that
every year but the implication that the
news side which Chris Wallace is a part
of and wants to protect from criticism
is doing some great job of informing us
look at Bill Hemmer stand aside as
Kenneth Starr says the letter is no big
deal the report is fine william bargain
say 100% a plus that's the news side
that Chris Wallace claims to be
defending absolute and total joke make
sure you're following the David Pakman
show on instagram at david pakman show
somebody put together a really funny
image where they added they photoshopped
sam cedars glasses on to me and his
haircut and a sweater vest which I
wasn't even actually aware with Sam's
thing but I guess he's known for so that
it's this sort of completing the look of
me stealing every element of sam cedars
visual presentation and we've posted it
to our instagram page at david pakman
show make sure you're following us there
while you're at it follow me at David
Pakman we will take a break and be back
with Josh Douglas right after this
today's episode is sponsored in part by
the BRD Bitcoin wallet whether you have
experience with Bitcoin and crypto
currencies or you've been wanting to
give it a try for the first time BRD
offers the most elegant easy to use
Bitcoin wallet out there it's an app on
Android and iOS lets you trade crypto
currencies store all of your Bitcoin and
crypto on the app totally free send and
receive Bitcoin with the app use a
credit card to purchase cryptocurrency
and it's 100% private and secure
virtually impossible for someone to hack
your account BRD themselves won't even
know your information there are no
logins no passwords you just use your
key to access your Bitcoin and you're
the only one who has access to it it was
the first ever Bitcoin wallet in the iOS
App Store they've been around since 2014
they have more than 2 million users BRD
is one of the oldest most established
and most trusted Bitcoin wallets in the
industry we recently interviewed Aaron
from the BRD team and it was a great
conversation you should search our
channel for it and check it out
all BRD wants to do is to make Bitcoin
more accessible and simpler to use for
those who want to use it and that's what
they've accomplished with their super
powerful easy to use app download it
it's
for anyone who's just getting started
with Bitcoin just as good if you already
know what you're doing I've put a link
underneath this video